hey guys it's justine and we're at ces
2019 and the first stop
here today is behind me this is the
world's
smartest yacht it's something that you
didn't even know that you needed we're
about to head in and do a little tour of
this
it's called the adonis we are hopping
aboard
the adonis and this is so awesome i got
my boots on
stepping aboard yeah pretty sick isn't
it wow it's incredible yeah so how long
have you guys been working on this
well in terms of technology i would say
it's evolved over
since the company was founded for 12
years but adonis in particular
uh it was about a two-year project and
we integrated all that technology and
products
into the yacht and we we built an
artificial intelligence concierge
service called angel so it's basically
all the things that you would find in a
smart home but now it's in a yacht
and it's incredible but better yes that
is most important
hi angel turn on lights
okay turning on the lightsaber now
also has like beauty aspects to it too
where it can it can detect your
skin tone and moisturizer and then
indicate what that status is
on on the interfaces throughout that's
really where's that i'll show you the
shopping component
it's it's everywhere it's everywhere
we'll show it to you downstairs okay
cool
the the dashes in the seating is also
like furious specialty
in the special markets with the
navigation and the monitoring of the
equipment as well
are you guys uh letting people do test
drives
right now come join us
oh really do you wanna yeah so i just
can detect who you are and then
identify me and set all the preferences
to what i like turn on lights
okay turning on the lights at master
cabin now
i would like to order some swimwear here
is a list of mossy swimwear
what would you like junk twilight i am
placing the order now
you can also order food menus
to the captains everything you order now
thank you anything else you need
do you need sunscreen no you're like i'm
good
don't let justine have voice activated
shopping activate chill out mode
oh yeah super chill fire oh
whoa whoa okay we've got blinds going
down over here
no wait you've got the fireplace
we should have ordered sunscreen right
hello hello everyone no one's waving
back no one's waiting
no hello so what is your favorite thing
about this boat the bart
as a whole yeah but like there's a lot
of little things like you had to pick
one thing
angel is definitely the highlight for me
it's something that i've worked on for a
long time and
it's part of my vision yeah being what
we're progressing to so
yeah to see it come alive here at ces
it's an amazing experience and i'm
really excited for what's going to come
next and how we're going to evolve that
tech
so what is coming next you'll have to
wait and see oh no
we'll be there
it's been a whole day i mean wow do you
want to say hi to my vlog
my vlog could you check out the gaming
monitors yeah it has leds on the back
that's awesome that's amazing
i need to read you my gaming space so
this is definitely something i want in
my future they look good
so one of the things that i wanted to do
this year is well number one i wanted to
redo my office and number two redo my
gaming setup so this is super exciting
we're now in the lg booth
and this over here is one of the brand
new lg ultrawide monitors
this is so incredible this is a 49 inch
monitor
5120 by 1440. this is
so great like i can't even imagine
editing on this thing actually i can't
imagine it
and it's incredible also over here these
are the ultra gear monitors
and they launched ultra gear last year
so basically it's rebranding
their gaming monitors to have a new name
these are all lg monitors with branded
and ultra gear
so what these have right here is they
also have the spherical lighting in the
back
so they have this reactive sound so if
you're playing a shooting game or
whatever it is that you're playing the
lights will react to the sound that is
coming through the monitor so these are
really cool
this is one of the newer ones this is
the 37.5 inch model and over here
we've got the 27 inch so behind here
like i mentioned the spherical lighting
if you want to check that out
it's all rgb so you can change the color
to kind of match whatever theme you're
going with but man that reactive sound
is something that i'm super interested
in trying out
i can't wait to redo my office this is
gonna be so fun
we've been competing on the apple watch
for quite a while and you beat me on the
last one
you had a good lead of like three weeks
i did and then i like
turned it up a notch chris's vacation
happened and then i did nothing
so it's all good so what have you seen
that you you're into so far
look at this this tv section i've seen
some interesting stuff from razer yeah
pretty quiet so far so far but you know
we're here
ces running in the friends
[Music]
so we're at ces day two and we were
checking out the karma rivero at the
booth yesterday and they have a concept
car there and they were like justine do
you want to take one for a ride tomorrow
this is the production model and it is
so
beautiful one of the things that i
thought was really cool about this car
is is the little keystone up here is
actually hand
painted every single one is a work of
art it's an electric car and you can get
50 miles on
one charge we're going to take this for
a ride with the gasoline you can get
about 300 miles
but i don't think we're gonna be going
that far today because we've only got
like an hour
let's get it i'm gonna get in now
okay get in here i got you
let's cruise we've got 233 miles we're
in sport mode
obviously this is how you change from
drive he didn't tell me how to change it
we probably just push it
debris break push p or np
gsd
okay so now we d what's the horn sound
like
oh we'll find out we're listening to all
of the songs with drive
in the titles uh oh
i'm what do you think it pulled over
where's your registration
do you have a glove box
[Music]
oh my god the police put the camera down
put the camera down
they're gonna know we're not doing
anything i don't care
i'm always just i get so nervous when i
see the police
i think that they just know that i'm
doing nothing
wrong do you know the songs yeah i've
got a fast car
let's let everyone know yeah
[Music]
this guy's looking at me give it a two
why are you putting in the window
i nailed that shot nailed it dust
good job and we made it back and now
we're going to put it in park
[Music]
we're back on the show floor and right
now we're heading into the south hall
and our first stop is going to be razer
yes
we've made it so we're checking out the
razer turret for xbox one and this is
really crazy because this is basically
turning your xbox into a pc
sort of environment because we've got a
keyboard here we've got the mouse pad
and this is so comfortable and it's
great because this will also work on
your pc too
so it's not just console but this little
mouse pad just pulls out just like this
i really love that you can also use it
for your pc too so this is actually some
health indicators too so i didn't do
very well
on my first wave so i died oh there it
is there it is see look
so those are lighting up now so that's
the indicator of the health on my
little guy here and he's not doing very
well oh gosh my ship is being wrecked
i'm getting wrecked guys so pre-orders
are out now they announced this last
year so i'm definitely excited to test
this out
we have a bit of a surprise for you okay
alexa
ask synapse to start a chroma party
yes you guys say no said i love dmx and
there is a freaking party happening
look at this is it nonstop this isn't
stainless steel so great
we are in the razor booth and they are
playing the scented version
of dmx for me this is incredible we're
having a chroma party right now
so these are the new nano leaf touch and
you can basically activate
anything just by touching them so you
can just bind this to
whatever sort of setup you want this one
is set to play music
this would be so great for parties
right now we're gonna go check out the
new razer hyper sense and i'm excited
about this because i feel like haptic
feedback in gaming and
watching movies or tv shows or anything
it's sort of that next step
and i'm not sure if anyone has done it
just quite yet as they have this is so
cool because the hypersense is enabled
in the mouse
in the wrist pad and even in this chair
so this is going to be
oh and the headset oh my goodness it is
in everything
so this is a fully immersive experience
are you ready am i ready do i lean back
how
what's my proper positioning
so just move it a little bit okay the
carpet's not letting me move
this is crazy so you guys can't feel it
but i can feel it because in my back
when i'm
reloading like i can feel the vibration
right here
and as i'm even running oh
the rocket launcher that was a wild
feeling whoa oh my gosh
this is so wild
i think the craziest thing is the chair
because you really do feel it
especially when i've launched these
rocket launchers and people wonder why
no one wants to leave their house
anymore we just ran into the insta360
booth and if you guys know i am obsessed
with this camera i've done so many
amazing photos and videos that i got in
hawaii
and we're going to take a look real
quick see what they have i see an
underwater housing
they've also got oh my god they have one
attached
to a drone i don't think maddie would
like a helmet too much
this is probably the biggest disc i have
seen at ces
other than the apple billboard is it360
has a recycling program
for the gopro so if you put your gopro
in here
into the recycling bin
[Laughter]
i'm on the floor this is incredible
all right see you later that's free
jenna this is for you a gift i'll bring
mine to recycling
so they also announced an 11k vr setup
it is called the tight this is going to
change the way that people create 360
content
i feel like one of the difficulties with
360 is creating the content and how
difficult it is but
i've been using the insta360 one which
is their consumer version it is so easy
because you basically just plug it right
into your phone and you can edit it into
any size any ratio
you can make yourself an instagram story
you can tweet it out you can basically
do anything and it's
honestly one of my favorite cameras from
the past year
cool story just stayed too cool
to add all right bye so
there's a fire alarm can you hey can you
get a shot of that real quick before the
fire
sure happens so that's even the fun part
of it so yeah just make sure okay so
that's the 11k
we gotta go we gotta go but wait i don't
think it's real
we don't care if it's real we're getting
out of here i'm not burning
but i didn't get to go to the dji booth
yet well you can burn and think about
the drone
no one's burning well you could say
here's your camera
okay i'm still i still have my cough
drop
jenna and i are getting the ces flu oh i
already had it for you
now i'm getting it but there's something
that i need to show you i saw this when
we were walking over here we're heading
to the dji booth but on the way there
we saw something what did you see you
got to see it
here it is what is it i don't know no
way
our future mode of transportation is it
concept
i know nothing about it okay so i'm not
asking so i know nothing about it i saw
it
i saw it with my eyes and i said jenna i
like that helmet me too
look how cute the little osmo pocket
muslim thing is oh my god
it's beautiful okay so the osmo pocket
is probably one of my favorite cameras
other than the insta360 that came out
but they're kind of two different things
but what i love about this is the gimbal
basically attaches right to your phone
and it's so steady it's so incredible
and you guys have already saw my video
but let's go look at it here at ces
their little display is so cute i wonder
if they have some of the accessories
because we don't have any accessories
yet i don't even have one
we have found the accessories we've got
the charging case the cover we already
have
the controller wheel the wireless module
we do have that one
3.5 millimeter adapter that's going to
be amazing
to do lobbed audio nd filters quick
release the accessory mount
the extension rod i don't the smartphone
adapters
the underwater housing oh
shoot so this is the new dji smart
controller and this thing looks
amazing because one of the things that
drives me crazy when i am actually using
it is
i will forget that i have my phone
connected to it so i'm always trying to
like tweet or text or something while
i'm flying
especially when i'm doing like the
hyperlapses
i'm playing against the computer because
i don't have any friends
i just lost on easy you saw nothing
you saw nothing
hey you want to see something
do it again no
this would be great when we have our
ranch we can
till the ground i think we well we can
harvest wheat so the tire
is bigger than my car
this is lovely how much do you think
this cost
700 and no no it's got to be like over a
million retract
it's got one million point like way over
like probably i mean one point five
let's move on
those are twenty breath of the milk hey
baby
take a picture
you guys thank you so much for watching
jenna thanks for making my video you
just
danced with a robot i did it was really
cool the robot dance with me it's super
cool found me and it's like we're
dancing now look okay they said that's
gonna be available within a month which
is kind of insane oh shopping
we definitely both need one yes yes we
do all right we're heading out there's
so much more to see at ces and we
honestly
i don't think we can even see it all if
we even try but
we'll see you guys next year 2020 ces
we'll see you
in a year wow wow we should start
prepping now so we're a little more
prepared
yes we gotta do we have to lift more
weights because these cameras are heavy
we're never prepared for ces
every year it's like oh surprise it's
arrived time is now
oh all right back to l.a that was weird
we don't do that we don't do that
you